the way human evolution has worked is
that humans are constantly toggling
between two main modes of thought a mode
of thought where we're focused on the
moment for survival issues right because
if you miss like a saber-toothed tiger
coming after you you know and you're
daydreaming like you're not gonna be
dead during much longer you don't think
but we also have this other really
important mode of thought on the
downtime when we don't have to be
vigilant about our environment where
we're constantly planning for the future
our brain has evolved to to toggle
between two main modes of thought the
moment processing and future planning
that's actually what the planning part
is actually what makes humans uniquely
human because other animals have a hard
time transcending the present moment so
we're constantly talking between these
two things and I would argue that for
optimal creativity you need to strike a
balance you need to come to what's what
we call the middle way and the middle
way is knowing when it's contextually
appropriate to pay attention to the
present environment for for survival as
well as gathering information and wow
yourself when that isn't necessary to
dip into your inner stream of
consciousness and plan for your future
to critical brain networks that are
involved in this toggling process
between the present moment and our
future planning is the default mode
network which I like to refer to is the
imagination network because all the
kinds of processes associated with this
brain network I think are associated
with imagination subway from like
perspective-taking and when I'm taking
the perspective someone else I'm
imagining what that person is thinking
right - today dreaming - thinking about
the future in a future planning it's all
you know imagination a lot of it has to
do with social imagination a particular
kind of imagination but I think it's a
you know it's definitely having to do
with imagination and the other major
brain network is the executive attention
Network executive attention Network is
really crucial for working memory such
as holding information in your mind in
consciousness and and processing and
manipulating it as well as focusing on
the outside world it's also important by
the way for focusing on your inner world
so you can be am I
daydreamer and when you're a mindful
daydreamer both of those brain networks
actually couple together right because
you're focusing that limited spotlight
of attention inward on your and so your
daydreams might become more focused when
these two brain networks are
collaborating with each other so these
brain networks are not always at odds
with each other there's a unique state
of consciousness when both of those
networks are on the same level of the
seesaw right and and that seems to be
creativity really really expert
meditators have been shown to have a
amazing executive attention Network
they're really really amazing and being
able to focus but that doesn't
necessarily relate to creativity you
could be the greatest most proficient
meditator in the universe and not have
it one iota of creativity I think that's
the honest truth like and you know you
go I go to some of these conferences you
know conversing these mindfulness
conferences and they're all like just
like who's off looking at like paying
attention to like be the speaker and
they and you look at them and they're
all so ways are focused on the speaker
because they've honed their their
mindful attention and I and I it drives
me crazy sometimes because I just want
to just scream daydream like it's okay
like like you know like like go back in
and make meaning out of that experience
you know and go and then go back out you
know it's that toggling process that the
creators are really good at so I
wouldn't make a case that I think a too
extreme in either direction either two
extreme day dreamers and there are
chronic day dreamers they need help a
lot of them you know like like see
psychiatrists because they can't stop a
day dreaming and I and I think on the
other end too we can become a too
mindful society where we lose fact of
the importance of dipping back into
create meaning out of that out of a
world that we're mindful of
you